the Austin Motor factory at Birmingham
already reaching new production levels
the car industry sealed
Birmingham's reputation as the workshop
of the world during the 20th century
cars dominated the city's economy and
then it's landscape today it's a city
built with the motorcar in mind the
famous Spaghetti Junction a symbol of
how many people's lives revolve around
their cars pedestrians became a
secondary concern in the city centre
relegated to underpasses beneath
increasingly congested roads but change
is coming with plans for a city where
the car is no longer king it'll be
redesigned less of this and more of this
will be clean air charges and most
controversially a ban on driving through
the city centre there'll be restrictions
near schools
- it sounds drastic but is welcomed by
people who are already trying to do
their bit children are dying from having
asthma attacks elderly and frail people
who already have health conditions air
pollution is and contributing to and
timely deaths it's not something that
any of us can be complacent about or
just ignore but the transport secretary
has warned the plans are extreme and
could kill the city centre if people
stop traveling in taxi drivers share
those fears that's gonna have a lot of
effect on our business and Joe public as
well and the shops in the city centre
who will try on people coming into city
centre and that's how their day-to-day
business runs and if that's gonna stop
shops not gonna make money and obviously
the taxi traders can also resolve this
machine measures air pollution levels
you can see that becomes 15,000 but it
because the car particularly diesel cars
in the future this a road could be
rebooted away from the city centre it
cuts the a38 then the park had to go
around
socially traveled for longer having more
pollution and that in although you'd
improve air quality in a city center
that has a potential of deteriorate air
quality in other places
Birmingham isn't the only city making
changes the government is working with
sixty other councils to but cars are
such a big part of this city's past and
present the future here will be very
different Becky Johnson Sky News
Birmingham